Hello everyone.
Welcome to NTA 404 and welcome
to Reinvent. I hope you all are having,
uh, some fun with all the nice
sessions just for you.
Uh, my name is Pranjit. I'm a solution architect
and I have with me my co-speaker,
uh, Marcus Mattson, also, uh,
solutions architect, and I hope
everyone's having a good day one.
Everyone doing all right,
enjoying its sessions.
All right, a deal. Nice.
And, uh,
uh, uh, thank you again for
spending next one hour with us. So today's
topic is AI code to production context
matters. How many of you, like, if I have a
quick raise of your hands, how many of you
are using some kind of AI coding assistant
to code?
Quite a few. OK, nice. How many of
you have started playing
or dabbling around with our
agentic ID tool Quiro?
OK, not bad. OK. All right.
So. In today's session,
what we're gonna cover is, uh, this is a
code talk, so we're gonna do a lot of coding,
uh, while you are here. But before that,
just to set the, uh, stage today,
we're gonna talk about some of the AI
code production problem like when you build, like
when you do vibe coding or you are doing some
kind of prompt engineering and creating
some nice code,
uh, what is the challenge that typically
happens when they go in production and how
we can.
Uh, like, do context engineering
to kind of
put those code, uh, make
those code like production ready,
and, uh, then, uh,
the next thing that we're gonna cover is, we're
gonna talk about some of the essential context
layers, uh, for your success
when you are building AI code,
and then, uh, some of the key takeaways
of from today's session, some of the workshops,
uh, that we want to highlight that you can get started
with. So, having said that.
Let's quickly, uh,
talk about a developer named
Sarah, OK? She's a senior
developer.
She started doing vibe coding and
she faced some challenges. Let's see what are the challenges
that she faced and how she overcome that.
Let's talk about a journey that I think every
developer knows deep down.
It's the move from that frantic adrenaline
fueled last minute hack to the calm
confidence you get from building something you know is
rock solid.
It's really a story about the hidden dangers
of just making it work.
You know the feeling, right? It's Friday afternoon,
a huge deadline is staring you down, and
the only thing anyone cares about is getting
something,
anything up and running for that demo.
That pressure, well, that's exactly where
our story kicks off.
All right, so let's set the scene.
This first part is all about a gamble.
It's about a very tempting but also very
dangerous way of developing software,
especially now that we've all got these incredibly
powerful AI tools right at our fingertips.
So let's meet Sarah. She's a talented
developer. She knows her stuff, but
right now she's completely up against
the wall. A really critical demo
is just a few hours away and she needs
a miracle,
fast. So what does she do?
She dives into what we're going to call vibe
coding.
She's just firing off prompts to her AI
tool, grabbing the code snippets it spits
out and stitching them together based on
her gut feeling.
There's no big architectural plan, no
deep thinking. It's all about speed and that
feeling of,
yeah, yeah, that looks about right.
And you know what? It totally works.
The demo goes off without a hitch.
The feature is a hit. The stakeholders
are thrilled, and Sarah's the hero of the
hour. She pulled it off.
But that amazing feeling, that rush
of confidence,
well, it's kind of built on sand.
Of course, that Friday high,
yeah, it doesn't last long
because the nice, clean, predictable world
of a demo is nothing like the absolute
chaos of a live production environment.
And this,
this is where that shortcut comes back to bite
her, hard.
This is when reality hits.
Monday morning rolls around, the code gets
pushed live, and almost instantly
alarms start going off.
The whole thing,
the system that worked so beautifully in the
demo, just completely falls apart
under the weight of real users and real world data.
It is an absolute catastrophe.
And look at the kinds of problems we're talking about.
These are not simple bugs. These are the
deep, gnarly, architectural
nightmares.
You've got race conditions, corrupting data,
massive security holes, compliance failures,
and memory leaks that are crashing servers left
and right.
These are the huge invisible icebergs
that vibe coding just sails straight into.
And this is the moment it all clicks
for Sarah. This is her big
aha moment.
The AI wasn't the problem at all.
It did exactly what she told it to do. The
problem was she didn't know what to ask
for. She asked for a feature, sure,
but what she actually needed was a production
ready system,
and those are two completely different things.
So this total disaster, it becomes a
massive turning point.
Sarah realizes she just can't work like this
anymore. It's time to evolve, to level up
from being a reactive vibe coder into something
way more intentional,
way more powerful, a
context architect.
Now, let's be super clear. This isn't
about her throwing out her AI tools. No
way. It's about getting way
smarter in how she uses them.
It's a shift from just asking for a chunk of
code to providing the AI with
deep, rich structural context,
so it can generate code that's not just working,
but is genuinely robust.
So how does she actually make this shift?
Well, she adopts a new framework.
You can think of it like a blueprint for success, a
way to feed the AI all the right information
from the very start.
Let's walk through these four layers of architecture
that pretty much change everything for her.
OK, here's how this blueprint works. It
all starts with requirements.
This is where she thinks through every possible edge
case, every failure mode, all that
security and compliance stuff.
Next up is design.
Here, she's planning things like concurrency to
avoid those exact race conditions that burned
her before.
Then comes implementation,
building the code from day one so that it's easy
to observe, scale, and maintain.
And finally, the operational layer.
This is where she's thinking ahead about monitoring for
things like memory leaks before it becomes
a 5 alarm fire.
This table really just lays it all out, doesn't it?
On one side, you have the vibe coder. They're reactive,
they use vague prompts, and they get code that's good
enough for a demo.
They're asking, what do I build? But the
context architect is systematic. They use
structured prompts to get genuinely production ready
code. They're asking the deeper questions,
why are we building this and how will this thing behave under
every possible kind Of stress.
So armed with this whole new mindset,
Sarah gets a shot at redemption,
and the stakes, they could not be
higher. Another urgent, super
critical request lands on her desk, but
this time it's right before the biggest,
most intense traffic day of the entire
year, Black Friday.
But this time is different. There's
no panic, there's no last minute vibe
coding.
She just calmly and methodically works through
her four layers, building out a comprehensive
plan. She then uses that plan
to create these incredibly detailed,
context-rich prompts for her AI assistant,
guiding it to build a system that is
resilient right from its core.
So Black Friday hits, the website
gets absolutely slammed with a
flood of traffic unlike anything they've ever
seen. The entire team is just
holding their breath, glued to the monitoring dashboards,
and the number of critical errors, the number of outages,
the amount of downtime,
it's a big, beautiful 0,
a perfect performance.
The system she's so carefully designed as
a context architect scales
up perfectly. It handles the
insane load without a single
hiccup. I mean, if that's not the ultimate
proof that this new approach works, I don't know what
is.
And really, that's the core lesson
of this whole journey.
The magic isn't the fact that AI can
write code for us.
The real skill, the thing that truly marks
the leap from a good developer to a
great one, is knowing what context
you need to feed it.
And so that brings us to the final question,
and this one's for you to think about.
The next time that deadline is looming and
the pressure is on, which one are you gonna be?
Are you gonna be the vibe coder, crossing your fingers
and just hoping for the best,
or are you going to be the context architect,
building for reality?
OK.
So, having seen
that, right, uh, these are some of the
challenges, right? Uh, or
why AI code fails in production. AI
models, they're trained on a
lot of code, right? But they don't
know your business.
There are certain AWS environment specific
information that you have in your AWS account,
but it is not aware of it, right?
Uh, it Is not aware of any kind of regulations
or security compliance
and any kind of other
compliance requirements that you are supposed
to take care of when you're developing code.
It is not aware of the cost implications.
Are there any challenges in respect to how
you want to architect your AWS
environment for any
production of the application, right? So,
having said that,
These are some of the context, uh, that we're
gonna see how we can address, like how we can layer
this context into
our solution which is called Quiro, the agentic
ID, uh, from prototype to production,
which gives you
a lot of flexibility how you can inject context
in runtime, how you can use the long term
memory within, uh, the
application itself to build something which you can deploy
on day one in production, right? So
some of them are like the how you can
create. Business context and feed that
still utilizing the entire context window
because context window is something that you
don't want to fill with all your documents dumping
into and filling all the space
to leave nothing for the LLM to be creative
enough to come up with something
useful for your production application. So you
need to know how you can utilize your context window
efficiently.
Uh, for your production ready application,
last but not the least is the AWS context.
So you need to make sure the
application that you're building, which you're planning to deploy on AWS,
are also following the best practices. We
call it well architected framework, right?
Uh, it,
if you have certain cost related constraints,
you want to also give that information
to the,
uh, the AI coding assistant,
how you can do that. So all those things we're gonna
look into, uh, the Quiro part of
it and then see how we can use Quiro.
And some of the features that we have in Qiro to
come up with the production of the applications. So
I'm gonna switch to my, uh, other
uh demo laptop, and we're gonna talk
about a gaming company. Let's say Sarah
is a, uh, is working in a gaming,
uh, company, and she's supposed to build a
game application, right? And how
she starts introducing
context, how she is utilizing those contexts
to be able to come up with a production application that
is ready to deploy on AWS.
So with that, I'm gonna switch
to my.
Yeah, and if you're like me, you've seen AI
coding assistants generate some really impressive
stuff, and then you've seen it create
some stuff that
uh lacked a little bit.
And so you're probably thinking, show me, and
that's what Pranjeet's gonna do.
All right. Uh, can anyone confirm, like,
are you able to see or do I need to zoom
more? You're
good? OK. All right.
So this is uh the Kiro
ID. There are two flavors to Kiro. One
is the CLI part of it. One is the ID.
So if anyone is like familiar with
like coding using keto CLI,
you can do that.
Uh, folks who are actually like maybe
working on Visual Studio,
it's a VS code for hero, so you
can get all your visual code settings.
On boarded to Quiro when you're deploying like the
uh installing it and you're uh you're
starting to use it. So for our session
we're gonna use the Quiro ID not the
Quiro CLA, but you have two flavors. So just
to let you know
now this is a
I've just set the stage. So what I've
done is initially I have.
Let me do,
OK. So I've set a
folder called a game app
and I have placed a Kiro logo over
here. That's just a blank
uh application with nothing inside it other than a logo
page and then.
What I'm gonna, uh, if you see the ghost icon
is where you would see
a lot of additional
features like agent hooks, you
have agent steering, and you have MCP
servers, right? So we're gonna cover all of them.
Now, uh, in the agent steering,
you see there's a
global steering rule called SE
global rules, which is
a condition that I put
for all my.
Applications that I'm gonna build with kiro
agentic ID. So what I want is this is the
global steering rule. So how do you, when
you actually go into the agent steering and
hit this.
Plus button, you have like 3 options over
here. The first one is
creating from scratch where if
you have any code base already
there in this repo, if
not, it's going to create some basic
uh markdown files. There's
one which is called global agent steering, and
there's one foundational steering rule. So
for the one that I'm showing here, it is the
global agent steering. That means it is
stored in
the home
folder of kero under the steering. So that
way this global. Rules are applicable for any
application that I build through Kiiro and I'm gonna show how it
is going to take care. So I have given like a specific
information of that when I'm gonna use
spec driven development, uh, instead of
vibe, uh, always, uh, create the
requirements, mark down document, uh,
and then, uh, also list, uh,
different persons, right? Uh,
when actually the requirements documents are created,
it doesn't give the persons, but I want that
the user stories and the
acceptance criteria that it creates should have a personal
attached. It, I also want like when it
is creating a design document,
it also should include an ER or entity
relationship diagram for me if there's a
database schema involved, right? And then
the other one is like when it is creating the tasks,
it should also,
uh, organize the task so that
like after each and every granular task I should
be able to like demo uh a unit
test like what exactly the
application looks like after this task, right? So
for our
project what I'm gonna do is.
I'll go back to this
folder structure.
Uh,
Bear with me.
So I'm gonna create a,
a specific steering rule. Steering rules
are something that is
uh specific to this
application. It is always going to refer to the steering
rules when it is trying to come up with the requirements
and the design and the task.
So,
Let me create it from scratch.
Uh, building rules. So these are my
standards that I always want
hero to take care of
when it is building an application. So it comes
with this template. It has inclusion
always on the top. That means it is always
going to include the specific instructions
that I'm gonna put over here when
it is trying to come up with the, uh,
requirements and a design.
So I'm gonna
paste it over here. So what I've done is, like I've
mentioned. Let's
say a game building application rules.
When you're, you're a helpful game building agent,
you must always adhere to like
the preferred languages. So let's say you're like
creating any Python
applications, so you can put those specific
information specific to your scenario, but you
can give any number of information
based on what your stand like standards are, what
your company standards are, what kind of coding
rules that you follow. So you can give all these
over here and then I'm gonna save it.
And I'm going to create one more markdown file,
which is specific to the styling
part of it. So what kind of colors that I
want. And
anything related to to design.
So I'm gonna come here.
And then I'm gonna create one more.
styling guy.
And light and then.
I'm gonna
Paste it over here. So if you see over here, I've given
like specific color schemas.
And some of the usage guidelines
and some design guidelines that I
like to
uh adhere when I'm actually building this
gaming application.
Now, I
will switch to Y. So as I mentioned,
right, Hero gives you flexibility. So we,
there are certain scenarios where Y coding is
relevant. Like if you want to build a quick prototype,
Y coding is still the go to path, right?
If you are building something which is production
ready, uh, definitely advised
to use peg-based coding which follows the typical
SDLC process of like planning first
rather than just prompting and praying like wipe
coding, right, so that it gives you the right
code because like typically in vi coding what
happens is that when you give a
Big prompted all the information, it starts
coding without even thinking, and then the code that
it comes out, you probably have to
like revise it so you go back and ask, OK,
can you add this? And then it goes and tries
to address that specific,
uh, last, uh, chat
history, and then it forgets what it has created
initially and then you go into regression
and you keep on troubleshooting to come up with a
appli like a a code that you can really
play with, right. Whereas in spec based
is more of like doing all the planning,
making sure they are approved like either
by your product manager or your architect team,
or even if it is you're a senior developer and you
have the ownership to, uh, approve all the
use cases, and then you start then, uh,
building the code so that the
code that is being built is adhering to all
the requirements and a design
that you have approved, right? So that's kind of difference between
vibe and spec based.
Right now,
so, so just a quick
on, on these documents you just created the,
the, uh, steering docks, the rules basically
the global are gonna be your organizational
standards and the others are specific to this
project and one of those was marked always
so that means whether you're using VIB or spec
it's gonna refer back to those
steering dock rules.
Yes, so
you can set certain guidelines at the global
steering level and then you. Have certain guidelines
at the like the workspace level
right? but then typically the workspace level
steering like if there's a collision between the
global and the workspace, uh,
the, the global steering rules
are not getting the precedence it's basically
the workspace specific guideline
that takes, uh, precedence
in respect to what it is going to build, right? So
that's how
that takes, uh, precedence, right? So yeah, good
question. Thanks, Marcus.
OK, now.
I just have an idea of this game that I want
to build. I want to build a flappy kiro
game right now. I can
use Vibe to just go and ask, like,
uh, build a very basic version
for my prototype for my ideation, right? So
maybe I can start with Vibe instead of like
starting with the spec best.
So I have an. Idea and I
paste a
prompt over here and if you see I just mentioned
I want to build a flappy kiro game please
create a very basic working version.
I've given some information like uh what
kind of canvas you should use for rendering
kiro character I mentioned there is a uh.
Image over there in the document
so it can refer to that. So I've given
some basic information. I just did vibe coding
and I told, OK, go and do for me
now while it is building that like,
uh, while it is coming up with the code, if you see over
here there are certain options like one
is the autopilot. So autopilot in the
sense I've given some autonomy to this
agentic ID so that it can take some,
uh, like, uh,
it can take some.
Actions without even asking me or prompting me, OK,
approved for everything. If I toggle
that off, it's gonna ask me for
everything that it does on the code base, right?
There are options of like
selecting different models from here. Like
you can select Opus model, you can select
cloud, or you can go in auto mode so that like
the agentic ID can
decide based on what kind of context and what
kind of task that it is doing. It can
toggle between different.
Uh,
models, right? So for me I've
selected cloud 4.5. So,
uh, I stick to that. And then the other
option is there's an option of adding images.
So let's say you
are coming out of a meeting, you did a whiteboarding
of a gaming application and you took
a picture of maybe an ERD diagram that you
have drawn out in the in the. Uh, uh,
meeting or you might have drawn an architecture
diagram, uh, with, with your stakeholders,
right? You can take a picture and you can upload it over
here and then it can, you can ask you
to kind of come up with the plan so
it has like a multimodal feature as well
where you can take some images and put it into the context
to come up with those requirements for you, right? So
it can do that
now. If you see
over here,
uh, it has,
this is what I, I wanted to show you. So when it
started like vibe coding
it included the steering documents, so the
one is the global one and then the couple
of them that I mentioned I created
specific to this workspace, right? And
then it says, OK, let's build a flappy game
together. So it went ahead and it created
some stuff. So if I go back
here in this one it.
Let's see. Once you answer this, OK, so
it has asking me to answer. So
I'll create a playable version
and all the games. So it, it is asking, so
if you see over here,
what I mentioned over here in the
app building rules, right? I asked.
That suggest
creative ways and then
take user's input and create a user
context MD steering file
to store user preferences as you
help the user build a game.
So it just didn't go and
started creating code just like vibe coding does,
right? So now it is asking me, OK,
can you address these questions. That I have
for you, uh, before even I go and
code, right? So that's why like you
are actually acting as a driver in the seat,
not giving
the whole autonomy to the ID
tool to come and, uh, uh, uh,
create the code, right? So maybe let me give
you, give some instructions over here, right?
So what visual studio do you
prefer? So let's say.
Classic
flappy bird game.
And then it says, obstacle. What should the obstacles
look like?
Traditional.
And then scoring, how should scoring work? plus
one?
Wine based on.
Sulfa equal time.
All right. So I've given that
information and then Quo goes.
And starts
OK. So now it has started the
HTML page
for the game.
And if you see over here, it has started appearing over
here, and then it has started creating the JavaScript.
Uh. So
once it is created, we're
going to look into the
The code itself. So, let me go
here.
And then let's see what it is building.
Yeah, it's starting to already give us
hints that this could start to become a more
complex application.
It's, it's asking about user preferences
and you're starting to wonder maybe vibe coding is
not going to be enough.
So let's see what it's got put together
so far.
So it has.
Yeah.
So, it is a very basic one, right? It
just doesn't do anything. It doesn't have any kind of
scoring, uh, like sto,
it is not storing any
information over here. So it's a very basic one just for
ideation, right? Now,
Once I'm done with the
Vibe coding, OK, I have a plan
now, and now what I want to
do is I want to add some features like I
want to store the player's score and
also the high score. I want to add some visual
effects like some kind of trail particles,
some kind of explosion effects, and
some sparkles like when it passes. Through some obstacles,
so there's like a lot of like additional features that I
want to, uh, add that means
that I'm gonna touch a lot of like
code base as well as I'm gonna create a lot of additional
files, and I want
this keyro to kind of come up with a plan
before even it starts coding, right? So that's why like
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna switch.
Over here
So I'm gonna open a
new context, uh, and
then I'm gonna a new window and then
I'm gonna move to spec,
and this is where the fun will start. So
what I've told, OK, help me add like save game
history and sports, right? I told about some
of the visual effects and then I told creative.
Minimum viable product for the above
features and I wanted it to
list only 5 tasks rather than
going more granular. Like if I don't give this
specific information,
it probably will come up with like 9 or 10
or maybe 11 steps, and it's very granular.
That's fine
for some developers for the sake of today's
time. I just wanted to limit it to 5 tasks. So
once I'm
given that, I'm gonna
hit enter and then if you
see. It now reads
again, always like when it starts doing something,
it always is
looking into the steering documents,
and then
now it is reading the existing code base.
And now it started creating the requirements
document. Now, if I hover over here,
And then if I go to specs,
it has created a folder and
then it has started creating a requirements document
for me
and as I have shown you
the first time I mentioned
that I want
so it has created the requirements document
and now it is waiting for me to like move to
design phase which is the next step but before even I
go there
is the user stories and the acceptance criteria
but what I mentioned is that I mentioned
give me the.
Personals as well, right? So if you
see over here this is something that it
created
based on my specific global steering
rules where I mentioned
introduce the persons and tell me which user
story is related to which persona,
right? So if you see over here. It has some user
stories
and some of the person is attached and what is the
acceptance criteria so it's the EIR's
notation right
now if I have validated everything looks good,
uh, I move to design phase
or else I can say, OK,
um.
Have you
Taken care of.
Deploying this
code to AWS
using
serverless.
Services.
So if I, I can still chat, right,
just like vibe coding, but I can ask,
OK, have you done that?
Let's see.
Now, I haven't moved into the design phase
yet, but then it says, OK, no,
the spec, OK, so it has come up with, no, the spec
focuses on the game enhancement features you
requested,
and it says the current game runs on HTML
5. If you would like to add AWS
deployment or back end,
OK, save, so it has given me, OK, would you like
to continue with the spec as is for visual or
add AWS deployment? So, let's say I
select 2.
As an option
And then it goes back and then updates
the same requirements documents. So until and unless
the requirements is finalized and I approve
it, it's not gonna move to the
design phase, right? And
so, yeah, so if you see over here, it has started.
Updating the requirements and I can look
like I can select here and you can
see the diff. So what is the additional
information that it is adding
on top of the existing one, right? So it
gets highlighted.
Over here now while it creates
those spec docs, it refers back to
the steering docks so that it makes sure
that it follows
the rules that you've given it and these
requirements, I mean it's requirements gathering,
right? That's one of the things that often misses
or gets missed in vibe coding and
and as we get further along, you'll start to see
how these specifications
are actually used invalidating the code
that the AI is creating or generating,
yeah. So now if everything
looks good, OK, let's move to the
design phase is where I hit the design phase,
right? Uh, and then,
And I say, OK,
government's good. And then it went to the design
phase. All right. So, let's go back
here. And then
I move to design.
So it's gonna start building the design which is
basically the technical architecture and
the mermaid diagram,
uh, for me to validate right now
while it is doing that, I wanted to showcase
over here like when I select the hosty
button I have additional
like tools that I've added like for example
some of the
existing AWS specific MCP
servers like one for the documentation
so that I always like whatever I am building, I
want to follow the best practices. So I always
want like Quiro to. Go and look into the
best practices for that appli like
uh based on whether it's a serverless or a
container based, right? So I want to follow
that so I, it can go and look into these tools,
uh, using the MCP servers. I want also
like, uh, and I'm gonna do that, OK, like
create an architecture diagram out of the
entire application that I've built so I can use the diagram
MCP server. So
there are additional like third party
MCP servers like for example Fetch like
let's say I'm building a trading system
application and there is some exist. Existing trading system
applications out there. I want to
like ask Quiro to go and
uh check the URL of the trading system
and compare with the one that I'm building or maybe any
application and see if there's any additional features
that I want to use in my
uh application, right? So it can go and
like look up existing like external
URL to come up with some
comparison and features say that I'm missing in
my application. So it can do a lot of like based on
what kind of incentive server that you want to integrate.
Uh, the other thing which is important is the
agent hoax,
and this is very interesting, and I'm gonna,
uh, show you like while it is building,
uh, still the design
document, uh, let me go
over here.
And this is something is built on
um the event-driven architecture of AWS
whereas let's say I want this
hook like
whenever.
Any
codebase file is.
Updated
and saved.
Please do the.
Unit testing.
To ensure it doesn't.
Break any?
Existing features. So if that is
a very basic like hook that I
want to use for an event ribbon like whenever a
new file or an existing file is updated, I
want at the back end, uh, for the agent
to go and make sure like nothing
breaks because of some additional code that I've introduced
or or uh updated an existing one.
So I can like create a
hook and what it does is that.
You can see like it has execution
queued, that means the design is
still being created when
uh this execution is queued so I can open
the task list so I can see like multiple
tasks right now. So right now if you see it is
in the design phase, so it's
doing the
uh design document
creation, whereas this. Task creating the hook
is still in the queue, right? So once the
previous one is completed, the next task is
going to, uh, execute. So you can
see the queue as well. All right,
now I'm gonna
switch back into my design
and let's see. So there's an
icon here where you want to like
look it,
look in a better one, OK, so you can like even
expand this
and you can look into the design in a
better view like.
Let me
scroll this part of you so that
it is much more visible to all of you, so
you can even.
Look, OK, this is the high-level architecture.
was the client side, server side,
and then the component interaction
flow.
And everything. So you can look into the
data model
and then
Still executing, so let me
Right over here. OK. So now it has, yeah,
so it has now completed and it says,
are we good with the design, right? Now, I'm
gonna close this one
and then I'm gonna say, OK, looks good to me.
Now, if you see over here,
It's
OK, so now it says, let
me see what it is doing. OK, so it has,
perfect. Now I will create the implementation plan
with task. So that's the next step.
So until and unless that's
completed, it's still waiting for the
generous spec. That means the entire 3
steps that it has to complete,
uh, before it creates the hook for me. So
now if I hover over to the task list, which
is very interesting, where it gives you the granular
task, but if you see over here, it's gonna create
only 5 of them for me.
Because I've mentioned, OK, don't create more than 5
tasks, right? And if you see
there are some
that are not highlighted, which are
like optional tasks. So,
here, once the task list is created,
uh, you can see there are a couple of options.
One is the Keep optional tasks,
uh, that is faster in VP or make
all tasks required if you,
if I select this one,
all the non-highlighted ones also becomes
mandatory so all the task has to be,
uh, like executed
before even I start the application. But for the
time being
I'm not gonna, uh, do all the tasks.
I'm gonna just keep optional tasks so I hit
that and now it just tells,
OK.
Perfect. So now it is going to
do only the 5 steps that I mentioned, right?
And the optional testers are marked as a
star, so you can like skip them for a faster
MVP.
Now,
I can hover over here and I can
look into the first task. I can select
the thunder button next to the start task. It's
gonna start this task first
and then it, it is going to wait for me
to then once it is completed, go to the
next task, or else I can do
over here.
Execute.
Our tasks in
Sequence.
Now, if I do that,
you would see.
OK. Now, it started
the first task, right? And you can like
look into view changes,
uh, what it is doing, which,
OK, still not yet. So, you can,
once it is
Started editing some existing.
OK, so.
Let's see.
It has executed. OK, now it has executed the hook,
which is the one that I mentioned. OK, the hook
is running right now. That means some of the,
if you see over here, which was interesting, uh,
it actually went in and
updated the game.
Dot JavaScript file. So
hence the auto unit testing
for the hook that I created that whenever it updates the
existing file it's gonna
uh execute the
specific hook to ensure that nothing
breaks, right? So it's still executing. I can look
into here. It's waiting for that
to execute.
And then it's still doing, yeah, and
this is a good point to point out when you create agent
hooks,
this is something we created that was very basic so that you
could see it in action, but in a, in
a real development mode you're gonna choose something that's
meaningful and impactful, uh, that's
going to,
uh,
be appropriate for the amount of times it gets invoked
and the, um.
Second, uh, thing that I was gonna point out is you, you'll
notice there's
broken up into tasks. One of the reasons you may
not want to execute
all tasks consistently on a larger
effort is because we talked about a context
window, and
these tasks, if you're going along,
uh, you'll find that Kiro
also keeps track of that context window
and if you're doing a large or a long
development. Uh, effort,
it will stop that session,
start a new context window, summarize it,
compact
what's in your context memory, and
move it into a new session.
So
one of the things you can do with these tasks is
usually or use them
to break up your work, uh, whether it's
because you've got a large project that has
multiple chunks or because you want
to break up your context window and
have a clean window for another
large task so that your context window
is clean and works more efficiently
for you, giving you better answers and getting
faster processes.
Yeah, when it does that, what does it do? It
does. It, it brings over that summary and it
brings those, uh, steering docks and the
spec docs back into the new session. Yeah,
that's right. And then, uh, talking about context window,
right? So I just invoke the kiro CLI
within the ID itself. So you just like
run the kiro hyphen CLI in the terminal
and then as Marcus mentioned,
like you can check at runtime how
much of context window you're using, right? So.
You can just type like slash context and you can
see, OK, I'm using like 12.8%
of the entire 100% context window
and then what are the different, uh, like
areas that this context window is filling up, right?
Uh, so you can see that on runtime and then
like the other thing that is very
important is like let's say the first task is
completed, right, and it's still running the hook for me
doing the unit testing.
The first task, it addresses
this requirements. So if you go to a requirements
document and see the 1.1, 1.2,
right, all these
specific requirements, it is basically tackling
through one single task, right? So
it also gives you that granularity of like
which requirements we are actually completing
based on which task and then like.
The other thing that is important is like the checkpointing
that means like let's say right now it is doing an
execute hook unit testing and
then it has updated some of the like
at the previous step it has updated some files.
I want to like I probably have done something wrong,
OK, or I want to like revert back.
I have an option of restore. So if I select
restore.
Like I can just
Remove those.
I just.
I can just
OK. It's just,
OK. It's just
like, OK, so I think it did something
wrong, but what I wanted to say is the restore
option is like you want to like
re-update the code base, OK, to the
previous state you can do that by executing
that restore button, right? OK,
and let me stop this,
uh, I think,
let's see, OK, enable
for the time being,
but then.
Let me open, uh,
the other thing. OK. So, uh you mentioned
about the
Context
window, let me bring that up.
So this is
Let me show you here.
OK, here is the thing.
Uh. I'm
going to bring this one. So I was
To your portion and let me enlarge
it. Here's the thing.
So, I was building a,
let's say, a trading system, right? Uh,
and I deployed it on AWS.
Now, if you see over here,
Uh, let me go here.
This session was too long, right, for
you, so it did the compaction,
right? So it basically went through all the
conversation history and then it created a new
uh session for me, OK, with all
the history for it. So it has created a new session
over here and then it did the same
thing like.
If I go on the top like it again including the steering
documents, so it came up. OK, I understood the
previous context from your conversation we did the compaction
of the context window and then yeah, so
it starts and while you're talking about this one in
particular, it, it's another, uh,
interesting call with Kiro. Those tabs each have their
own context.
So let's say you're working on something
that's more in depth in one tab
and you want to open up another tab but keep that
context as clean as possible,
you can open up another tab, just use haiku
in it, for example,
have a conversation about it, do some more planning,
maybe create some more steering
docks, more specs, more requirements, and
then work them back into the other, but keeping
the other context as clean as you, uh,
can. Yeah.
So, while that is like executing,
OK, this is something that I already, like,
for example,
Built it, right, the same uh
gaming application,
right? And
What I did is that, OK.
The other thing is very important is like if you
are using any kind of git report, right, you want
to commit. So I, the best practice
that we typically uh uh advise
is like whenever you have something which is,
uh,
a demoable solution, right,
do more git commits, right? OK, connect. Twitter
get report and do a commit, do an iterative,
OK. If you think, OK, this is the right time to commit it,
uh, just commit it and then come back and, uh,
uh, like build on top of that, right, so that you don't
lose the code base that you think you really like
it. So that's another best practice, right?
Uh,
now. If you see over
here, uh, let's see which, OK,
so. Here's
the one thing, right? So, let's see
which one.
This one, OK.
So,
it created a, so
this, this is an existing uh gaming
application, OK. It did all
the advanced features that I mentioned
and then if I open
the.
Gaming application with all the
updates.
And then if I bring it over
here, I created a pack kilo,
and it
has an ability to
save the high scoring. It has
those. Like trailing
effects that I mentioned and all that. So
I created this application in like maybe less
than 20 minutes, right, uh, building that
so I can like use VIP
like, uh, spec-based coding, move from VIP
coding for like doing proper planning,
uh, approving all the requirements, design and
task and everything, and then, uh,
that's how like you build like any kind of production
ready application which is, uh, and then the
final thing is like the AWS deployment,
right? So if you see over here, uh,
in this one.
If I go back here,
I know, page.
I'm struggling. OK.
So,
I did, like I told, OK,
even Quiro, right? I asked, OK, can you create
an AWS cost analysis because
I'm very concerned about cost. OK, tell me, like if there
are 10,000 users right now, OK,
using this application when it is deployed, uh,
on AWS,
how would that look like? So it created an executive summary
for me. Right?
Something like this. So it went in and
looked into all the uh
infrastructure that it is using for
hosting this application,
and then it did a cost breakdown
by service. So it created a very detailed
analysis of like cost analysis.
The other thing is, uh,
I asked him, OK,
can you create,
like if I ask here.
Can you
create
Uh,
AWS,
uh, I think it is too small, right? So architecture.
Diagram using AWS.
Diagram
Server.
So this is something like, OK, I have built the
application, but I want to create an architecture diagram, right? So
it says, OK, I'll create an architecture
diagram for you for the Pack hero game.
Now what it is doing is that it is using the MCP
tools. So here you have the diagram MCP
server. So it is taking all the icons
from there
and then.
is creating an architecture diagram for
me. And then
It's gonna wait
for me and then, OK, I want to allow it
to generate the diagram.
So you can like, so this is something more of
a runtime, OK, where you're not like putting
everything into the context, but you are like
calling on runtime some of the additional
external tools, right? And then the
other thing if you see over here, there's another
option here
which is the
hash button, right? So.
OK, there is.
My screen froze on me
for some, OK,
interesting. My screen froze on me, but
then let me.
So generated,
if you see over here, this is a folder. It
created an
architecture diagram for me. Let me bring
to this one.
OK, that's a nice
small
architecture diagram
that it has created using the diagram server,
right? Now,
I don't know. I cannot.
You, OK, here is this, so
you, if you type hash
and then there are like
certain additional context that you can inject, like
let's say I have this URL and I
can reference the URL like, OK, I have an external
URL
something like
example.com and then look
into that.
Look into this
gaming.
Application
and come up with a
Comparison of the feature set that I want to utilize
so you can
like use peg-based coding and the
conversation with that using some additional
tools that is there within the kiro agenttic ID
uh to do some kind of additional analysis
use, uh,
so, so that's kind of something which is very
interesting, right? uh.
Yeah, I think pretty much
that's all any questions so far based on the ID?
Yup, good.
A bit of a question between the specs and the steering.
Show here we had a very fairly simple demo
here
but in a more mature application you see those getting
quite longer. So
yeah, so the question is pretty simple
application. The steering and the spec docs
here pretty small.
What does the context window look like when you
add. A larger project
you're doing a significant refactor
of an enterprise application. What happens?
So that's when you start talking more
about. Uh, you will have multiple
phases. You break the whole project into phases,
uh, is one piece,
and I'll, I'll come back and bring it together in more detail.
Uh,
Pranjeet showed how some of these rules
and these, uh,
steering docks
are listed as always. You've got other
options. Don't always include them,
uh, and also, so when you've got
multiple phases of a project, you can have different
specs. So I've got one example that
has 10 different
specs. And each spec has its
own set of requirements,
uh,
design, and tasks.
An example, uh,
I could have
the, or I, I've got, um,
a particular enhancement. I've got a feature, a new
feature. I got an MVP first that took,
you know, two specs. Then I'm like, OK, this is
great for an MVP. Everybody loved it.
Let's do some feature enhancements. Call it sprint 1,
sprint 2, whatever you've got.
And then so you build that in there and
you create a spec doc for that set of feature
enhancements. I've got another
spec doc where
I added a feature,
and I really want that feature but it broke some stuff.
So now I've got another spec
instead of um.
Design and implementation tasks that
go back and help me
uh refactor
that piece and so that's how
you would do it now getting back to the context window.
Uh, if you haven't found it
before in your AI uses, uh, model.gov,
it gives you a list of all of the different models
that are, I don't know if it's all, but most
of the models that are out there, you can see, uh,
approximate price per million tokens.
You can see
size of the context window,
and when you look at that,
try to match
the model
with the work that you're doing,
because, yeah, it, it what could you
do a context, uh, show like, uh,
back in the KOCLI.
Do you guys have like a
Is there like a good ratio to shoot for?
We were talking about ratios and that's, it's
interesting and, and I, it may not answer. So the
question was, is there a ratio we shoot for?
Um, uh, what I was gonna say is the context
show. You'll
notice now I'm not getting just
how much is used per category. I'm actually
seeing what files
are being used. That gives you a better idea of what's
being used and what goes into it. Do I really need this?
So, um, ratio,
uh,
the ratio that we found, uh, is
it could range when you're creating code.
You could have a simple,
uh,
you know, generate a spec for doing
an enterprise billing solution.
It could be 1 to 100. You
could do what Pranjit was doing, which is a little more
detailed, and, and constrain
it, and it's more of a 1 to 10, 1
to 20. But one thing you'll find just in general
context ratios or or token ratios
into input output. Is that what you're getting at is inputs and
outputs? OK, so input.
Uh, generating code
1 to 10 to 1 to 100 depending upon
things. Um, if you're doing translation,
uh, 1 to 1, if you're doing
something along the lines of
a summarization, it might be just the opposite. I've
got 100 to 1 or 10 to 1 where I'm giving
it this and say summarize this for me.
So it's an inverse of that, um, just
general Q&A
1 to 31 to 5. I ask a question, you
give me. Some degree of concise
or verbose answer, but in
for what we're talking about code development, it could range
from
a 1 to 10 to 1 to 100
ratio,
depending upon things like steering docks, constraints,
and how you prompt it.
Yeah, it's typically like, uh, if you input like
I've seen like at least for Kido like or
some other tools like it's like 100 input token,
you get 1 output token, right? So that's
the reason, right? Like we consider
context window as the real estate that you
want to utilize it efficiently because like
you don't want to dump everything within the context and
like think like it's gonna create something wonderful for you,
right? So very like important how
you want to utilize the context window. That's why like
this key OCL and the tools that you have is like
showing you those how you're utilizing the context
window and how you can like. Are you nearing to the
compaction and things like that? You can do it
even up front, OK, like using some of the commands
like slash Compact and all that, right? So
yeah, that's important.
Now, uh,
like, as I mentioned, like I was just showing
like when you guys were having a conversation, a trading system
that I built, right? OK, so you can build like
this is just for like the time of that
we have like an hour, OK, how we can showcase
some of the features and some of the tools
that are there within the kiro agentic
ID, OK, which will help you from a context
engineering side of it. Right now we have gone
through this like just. A summary of what we
went over,
uh, we use like white coding to
start the ideation phase, then we moved to the
spec-based coding, and then we, uh,
like it created the user stories and acceptance
criteria at the requirements phase,
uh, just like any SDLC process, we call it
AIDLC or artificial intelligence
DLC, right?
Uh, and then the design phase is where you're gonna
look into all the architecture diagram,
the mermaid flow, the, the system architecture,
and everything, and then, uh, once you are
fine with those, you move to the task which can
be more granular.
And whether you have like additional
optional task as well which you can make them uh
like mandatory,
right? And there's one very important thing that was
uh like after it went GA
uh just a few weeks back, uh,
a property-based testing or PBT which
is basically not just unit testing
of just a specific module that you have developed
with agentic ID but making
sure like if you're doing some code update or
creating new code, is it gonna, uh,
go back and look into the requirements document
and see like if it is. Like aligning to
what you initially said to build, right, so
the property based testing is something,
uh, it
talks about like correctness property, and then it's basically
embedded within the design markdown
file where you go scroll all the way down. It
shows all the property based testing. Like these are the property
testing that is aligned to these requirements,
and it's gonna check those OK at certain interval
based on what,
uh, you're building, right, using some of the tasks.
So that those are the important thing. And then you come up
with a working product. Now
some of the advantages both for developers
and for the. Organizations like, uh,
you reduce time for fixing some of the
code that you generate through AI,
uh, you build production ready solutions from
day one rather than just like, uh,
prompting and praying something good comes out. You
become a context architect, not just a code reviewer,
right? So you're gonna use your own,
uh, knowledge, right, that you have acquired
from so long working on different tools and
technologies and frameworks, right? So
that's very important. That's not gonna go away. And
also how you can use like if you're building on AWS,
the best practices. Like I've shown some of the MCP
server. There are like more like cost related
MCP server. There's like, uh,
like cloud formation, uh, MCP
server and all those things. Like there's like more than
50 of them already out there, right?
Uh, and then from the organization, OK, you're
not, they're not gonna get a very big AWS
bill just because like,
uh, uh, AI code didn't even, uh, uh,
like understand the cost implications of
like is it building something like
is it like spinning up big containers or you see
to instances, things like that, right? So very
important, and then. Now the security and compliance
like mostly for financial industry, insurance
industry, how you're dealing with PHI PII
data, right? Are there any other government
standards that it has to adhere to, right? You
can do those vibe coding and the spec-based
coding. You can like have that conversation and
like make sure those are like embedded within the markdown
files or add those phases
before even it starts coding. So plan before you
build, right? That's kind of the idea.
And then, uh, faster time to market and,
uh, the tech debt, right? Like when you do vibe
coding, OK, you gather a lot of like. Technical
debt because like there's a lot of unnecessary code that
is not needed, right? So how you can
improve that and reduce some of the tech. So
those are some of the benefits for the
organizations and this is something that I wanted
to highlight like Andres Karpati, you probably know
the founder of OpenAI, one of the co-founder, has
mentioned in one of his session LLMs
are the new CPUs, which is more of like
context processing units. So context is very important
and how you move from prompt engineering
to the context engineering is a new era
that we are gonna go into right next year. So.
Uh,
as I mentioned, some of the resources, this is,
these are some of the QR codes. Please take a
picture if you want.
The first one is very, uh, interesting, which is like
the context engineering versus white coding, when to
use what. It's not and or or.
It's basically based on your use
case. OK, if you're building a quick prototype for going
into a, uh, uh, uh, a meeting,
OK, where you want to just show the art of the possible,
probably why coding is the. A way to go. But if you're
planning to build a production with the application, it's not
the right step, right?
Uh, the Quiro website to get started, how you can download
and set up your workspaces, and
then this is an interesting workshop, like AI-driven
dev with Quiro workshop. It takes you to the
workshop of the AWS where you can like actually
do hands-on,
how you can use white coding spec based
on some of the other additional resources that I shared
today, like some of the additional features.
Uh, and with that,
I think we come to the conclusion this is, uh, our
email address if you want to connect or
happy, uh, like connect over LinkedIn and
please, uh, like feedback is a gift. So
if there's anything that we can improve upon, if there's
anything that we didn't
meet your expectations based on the sessions that we have,
please feel free to give your honest feedback, right?
So yeah, any questions if you
have some time.
Gives you microservices
and you're just getting started
over there. What are some steps that
you should follow
for existing.
Yeah, so that, so let me rephrase
for the audiences, for someone who is going to offline,
uh, hear this, uh, the question is
basically what about the legacy applications, right? Like
how do we modernize or how do you like
start you like
playing with those and like modernize this was the same
question I was having with someone else like.
There's a use case over here, OK? It's just
one, like two patterns that we have showed here. They're
like 100 types of patterns.
So one of the patterns that I have seen is like there is a,
and just to give an example, uh, legacy
Java application,
right, that's been running for like 1015 years
with some outdated Java version, some of the
security challenges, right?
So there was this use case where like the stakeholders
are really concerned and they want to migrate
to a more modern architecture,
but it's a lot of significant
investment for the key resources, probably the developers
that have built. OK, have left the organization, right?
So how do you like squeeze that time frame
and use Quiro,
right, to give that code base, like
point to the code base and then let it
like use the spec-based coding to come up with
that modern cloud native, like if it is cloud
is the right way, uh, come up with the
discovery and the analysis part of it
and what would be the to be architecture so you can
do all that roadmap analysis and come up
with that,
uh, plan, uh, in a detailed fashion, OK,
which you can use like once you get approval from
your stakeholders to kind of then. Start
building on like uh small task
or sublevel task on addressing some of the specific
components within the legacy application to
move to a more modern cloud native architecture
at like it's like a crawl walk
runs process right that we typically follow. So
there's use case over there, OK, we have
workshops of how you can get started
on dealing with some of the legacy
applications and how you can use that, uh, key
road to kind of,
uh, build modern architecture and like,
uh, like modernize the legacy
applications. So there are use cases around that as well.
OK. If I can add
my 2 cents,
agree with everything he just said,
but I got 2 minutes. I think I can, I can enhance it.
Yep, Greenfield's
really easy, right? It's the brown field that you got
to do a little more work on it.
So you've got an enterprise architecture diagram, right?
I, or if not,
make one, or he'll I have, have Claude
Kiro help you, but Claude is multi
or Kiro's multimodal.
So you can take a picture or an image
of that enterprise diagram,
feed it in.
And then start at that level
and then, you know,
provide anything you want about your microservices architecture.
Do you wanna change everything? Are you, uh,
updating for versions, etc.
but something you can go back to your hotel room
tonight, get the diagram, feed it
into Quiro
as an image and say help me develop
a solution,
uh, for updating, upgrading,
refactoring, whatever you need to do.
Start from there, work your way down into the details,
you break up each one of those microservices into its own
set of specs.
All right. If there's any
questions, we'll wrap up here, but thank you
again for staying with us. Hopefully, it was helpful.
And yeah, thank you.